that got cancelled we only did three
seasons is it not going anymore I don't
know truly the answer to that I think
that there's the talk that it could
possibly be something that certain
people want to
do but it's a really difficult show to
shoot man it is we shot 33 episodes in
six years 33 episodes in six
years how is that
possible that's 33 divided by 6 is 5.2
episodes a
year was it
expensive okay so you're getting paid
the same as an actor so if you're only
doing five episodes It's not really
worth your time no it became an actual
real issue because there would be so
much time in
between uh between Seasons because Seth
wanted to write
everything um himself so it would just
takes so much time and at one point we
were like we have to like fight the
studio to like give us a holding fee or
something because you know Jay Lee was
eating Saltines and Gatorade at one
point because we just couldn't afford
anything it was horrible wow I had no
idea wait so you play hockey did you
ever play with with uh my ex-husband
Scott Grimes um I don't think I've
played with Scott GMS but I knew him
from years ago big hockey guy
yeah also met on that show which is
great because he's still one of my best
friends in the world so he still friends
after you got divorced yeah he just text
me right now we're planning going on a
trip that is unbelievable how do you get
married and then immediately get
divorced and still are best friends that
doesn't make sense it doesn't I know
honestly I think being thrust back into
like another season of the show after
everything we started off as best Pals
so we were you know always just you know
doing weird stuff to each other on set
not that sounded that sounded dirty I
didn't mean that like that we were just
always picking on each other and play
very playful yeah playful right right
right and then you know one day we just
hooked up yeah it was really good and
then that just kind of became this thing
that we were sneaking for a year on the
show and then it escalated into what it
probably shouldn't have
you
know so we tried it didn't work well
good for you you're mature two people
that are mature that appreciate each
other it didn't work out the way they
thought and gave it a shot moving on uh
hey guys I'm doing another live podcast
downtown LA at the Regent Theater and my
special guest for January 24th is
Kristen rer Breaking Bad Jessica Jones
this is going to be a sold out event I
know it it's going to be exciting and uh
there's a meet and greet and so much fun
that's going to happen January 24th so
make sure you get tickets as soon as
possible downtown Los Angeles at the
Regent inside of you with Michael Rosen
bomb with special guest Kristen Ritter
I'm so
excited